We are now in a better position to understand the
details of Network Address Translation. The trick whereby one public
IP address is able to serve many computers on a
private network, be it a home, a business or a
coffee shop that we discussed earlier. Recalling our earlier scenario,
your combined modem/router has this public IP address and your
computer has this private IP. When you send a packet
to the Udacity site, the router switches out your IP address
for its own. This way the Udacity site
will know where to send the response. The router
also however, changes the port number and the transport
layer packet and it remembers the translation between. Your
private IP and port number and this public port
number that it sent as part of a message.
This way, when Udacity sends a packet back, notice
how he flips the destination and source IP's and
the destination source ports. Your router then
can change the IP and port number back
so that the packet gets routed to your
computer. Instead of to your printer, and to
the right application. Like this. So the destination
IP becomes yours and the port number becomes
the same one that you originally sent, so
the packet gets routed to the correct application.